جراح سعانه بعامل نظافه لاجراء عمليه
حادثه غريبه في مستشفى الماني طبيب جراح
استعان بعامل نظافه لاجراء عمليه لاحد
المرضى الواقعه حدثت في مستشفى جامعه ميمز
الالمانيه عام 2020 الطبيب قرر اجراء
عمليه بتر لاصبع قدم مريض رغم عدم توفر
مساعد مؤهل من الكادر الطبي وقت اجراء
العمليه الطبيب طلب من عامل النظافه
تثبيته ساق المريض الذي عانى من اضطرابات
جسديه بعد تلقيه المخدر كما ساعده في
تمرير الادوات الجراحيه لهم لكن مدير
المستشفى شاهد عامل النظافه داخل غرفه
العمليات حاملا بيده ضمادات ملطخه بالدماء
المريض لم يعاني من اي مضاعفات لكن اداره
المستشفى طردت الطبيب وفصلته من العمل
واعتذرت عن الواقعه قائله ان ذلك لا ينبغي
ان يحدث تحت اي ظرف